you to want squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve une troisième fois sur ce fort
s il ya eu une nouvelle version de la
fac est sorti la version 0.02 ya pas mal
de nouveautés notamment des requins dans
l'eau peut désormais faire l'incroyable
immense bateau si je puis dire de 1 m
sur 30 cm c'est pas mal on peut aussi
parler des coups à une grande avancée
certains diront que c'est en fait une
danse bref là on est super bien là bas
j'ai fait mon chêne [ __ ] on est super
mal boîte protéger moi c'est quoi ça mon
gars
d'accord je peux me des points avec un
bout de bois badiane j'ai pas trop aimé
des fonds avec un bout de bois
disons que ma hache est nettement plus
efficace ok on va pouvoir faire
cocktails molotov qu'est-ce qui se passe
un voile à aller à la taille de la
tortue non on revient dans trois heures
elle est encore là et c'est d'atteindre
l'autre il atteindra un jour ne perd pas
espoir
c'est promis un parcours vous dégagez
elle a réussi plus tard elle avait une
semaine et demie 1 mais il faut un peu
un sap et tous là dedans on a quoi
encore un cocktail molotov plus talent
va être l'hôte hoffman là une balle de
tennis assez génial pour faire diversion
allez va chercher indigènes on va aussi
bien portée compagnie c'est ça je te
fais les gratouilles sur le bio express
bruit d'un moustique attend une quoi on
dérape et wamu secourir une femme qui
agonise caché jusqu'à lui faudrait une
puce électronique donc je vais enfin je
retourne dans l'avion c'est mon à trois
cocktails molotov h des mouettes qui
nous suivent et qui veulent défoncer les
ennemis j'ai appris plein de trucs là
c'est fini les débuts où je me faisais
décapités par des indigènes au juste que
je retrouve l'avion aviron oui c'est une
blague quoi un avion un avion mais ce
que quelqu'un qui a perdu un avion un
jour au hockey mon gars attendez attend
deux secondes deux secondes juste c'est
bon c'est bon là ou là ou là mon gars
vas-y bien là tiens qu'est ce tu dit ça
mon gars au les gsm health effects vas-y
attaque moi j'te par moi qui tu vas
faire et tu vas faire c'est sa part le
courant avec ton slip sale [ __ ]
ben voilà on s'est mis bien un il en
reste comme un décor pièce à leurs taux
on a plus de cocktails pas de problème
bon bah ça fait plaisir un début de
vidéo on défonce de l'indigène moi ça me
fait plaisir face à moi voilà qu'est ce
tu dis de ça mon gars tu as peur brute
dans les flammes de l'enfer
auquel cas le brûler la mal aux cuisses
regarder elle se protège les cuisses ah
non là les jeux décédé une semaine elles
doivent tout mourir alors à aux [ __ ]
âme lui c'est le protège toi protège toi
protège toi c'est ça va arriver en
courant le feu le feu le feu
moi je propose une bonne nuit tranquille
et sûr le sauvegarder alors à mon réveil
cette fois tu es toujours là [ __ ]
est-ce qu'on fait le méga totem de ouf
allez on fait mégatonnes bah oui mais a
carrément il faut tuer quoi tu es 200
personnes que pour faire ce totem
sérieusement ça vous fait quoi un devoir
que pour une fois on se débrouille bien
sûr ce juste amis à des indigènes juste
là mais non mais attends ils ont ramené
les renforts quoi vite vite vite mange
mange mange mange à l'écrit [ __ ] de la
pain cuit et il faisait pas encore de
cuisson rapide à l'époque il faut leur
totem comme ça devant chez moi je vous
ai paix pour qui vous a jamais si je le
tue lui vu qu'il a déjà deux paires de
bras
accroché à ses omoplates ça fera
grandement avancer mon totem
alors je n'en ai tout écart attendez on
veut faire ça va faire ça regardez moi
bien parce que c'est la dernière fois
qu'on voyait au [ __ ] il va nous
rapporter tellement de bras tellement de
jambes regardez elle s'enflamme et et le
dernier reste posée quoi je fais ma
prière week end désolé je nomme en fait
pas désolé du tout voilà c'est ça dégage
l efo blé super fours var il fait
semblant s'expose au regard des regarder
la fourberie d'un [ __ ] de merde
ok je compte changement pardon pardon
pardon pardon mais on 11 bat en plein
combat il se repose pour faire je suis
par contre mais ces chocs faut rester
autour du feu voilà je suis non mais
voilà [ __ ] mais tom veut savoir tu as
froid tapas froid je te laisse faire ta
prière sans problème à ya aucun problème
vraiment j'y vois pas d'inconvénient
vraiment gentil wata non non coup mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça mais ce mec
avait bouffé du c4 avant qu est ce qu il
a fait non mais chez les gones mais
c'est pas drôle au fond hockey on se
retrouve dans la grotte extermina grotte
voilà je vais appeler comme ça y'a plein
de saut et une jambe enfoncé dans le sol
d'accord donc je suis juste dans un
endroit vraiment bizarre d'accord il ya
plein de pierres qui a des crânes pardon
pardon écrin très bien là même qui
volent quoi c'est pas intimidant [ __ ]
non mais attends mais ça ça va finir sur
un décès wada mais qu'est ce que c'est
que cette chose battant mais c'est
sérieux
nommé regarder quoi tu sais que cette
chose on dirait une main qui est comme
ça voilà on dirait trois femmes qui sont
reliés par les fesses c'est vrai
regardez je peux pas courir en plus pour
moi tant pis aller on n'accepte tu as
les aveugles quoi en fait
waaa tank et la partie des gens chez eux
où ça marche ils partent sur un bon gros
délire de gymnastique artistique
regarder et un et deux et trois et
quatre au sol m essayons un jour est ce
que je pourrai retrouver amis sauront
pas jusqu'au lâcher un peu gros quand
même tout ce qui se passe au nom au
[ __ ] faut que je fous ont joué la
discrétion à je ne paie pas pour rien
faites attention à vous depuis la mise à
jour je peux rester appuyé sur clic
droit pour parer aux coups oui c'est un
timide je sais aller marcher à reculons
en espérant que on trouve la sortie
comme ça ok si l'air mûr qui est
derrière moi donc je suppose qu'on n'a
pas trouvé la sortie
non non elle fait quoi lui il me tape
n'arrête mais tu es chez toi mon gars à
des marchés toutefois comme ça je ne t'a
pas je te regarder juste un bon je crois
qu'on a un peu mal barré
allez l'esquivé maintenant pas en
courant l on trouve la sortie donc c'est
carrément pas la même grande que
d'habitude ça fait partie de la mise à
jour maintenant cependant des grottes
aléatoire avec les gens qui nous
regardent avec quatre bras et trois
crânes
bon alors toi faute affronter le chef si
je tâche et je te tue d'arranger le
respecte tout le monde mais attendez
vous avez la peau dure les mecs la rue
la tête
ah bah voilà juste là comme ça ça marche
donc toi je suppose que tu es le dieu de
tous ces gens là vu comment tu es
d'accord en pleine lévitation à on peut
casser ça pas du tout ça c'est juste
pour monter dessus pour faire un peu
plus imposant un jeu voit une petite
brèche là bas un petit peu de jours on
s'en sort on s'en sort allait au oui
c'est ça qu'on veut
lancry immense un bas aussi génial c'est
une sorte de lens d'accord c'est pour
chasser le poisson y est ravagée pas
trop chez c'est un poisson mais bon on
s'en bat les steaks venez jeanne poisson
chaque allée suivant chaque allée passer
de vraies entreprises à lui sur le quoi
cet homme quand ils chassent il ne fait
pas semblant
quatre espèces en voie de disparition
par sa faute allez on retourne à la
maison et là on fait un vrai attentat
chez indigène ouvrir une guerre civile
mois contre une armée de miller
d'hygiène voilà c'est pas très équitable
mais on aime ça et qu'on peut les brûler
maintenant alors ce que je propose c'est
de tester de manière immédiate qui ne
teste pas ne teste pas ceci n'est pas un
proverbe c'est parti autant de bruit et
les oiseaux et ça marche ça fait partie
de la mise à jour ça marche ça sert
absolument à rien du couple aurait
ramassé ainsi une plume
alors pour le moment les plus fous je
sais pas trop à quoi elles servent et
mais franchement non je veux dire on est
bien mais on n'est pas bien
non non non non non non non non à ce
qu'on appelle avoir le faut que ces bons
chiffres le chercher dans l'eau attendez
on a carrément au plat et elle prend
forme
il manque cette tête je peux pas lui
voler la tête pour la mettre sur mon
totem à moi on va sur le bateau et
ensuite on sauvegarde obtenir des
requins l'avoir regardé on voit ok c'est
bon on est sauvés alors on now
mais il ya masse de bouffe ici mais ce
jeune homme puis regardez c'est
magnifique je sais plus là j'ai le choix
des bas des bars sucré ou alors du
poisson ou alors des gens même même si
elles sont pas rasé on s'emballe et
c'est que je sais plus j'ai trop de
choix attention que les gars
au total il est prêt on se met à des
jambes à la maman s'en fout ah mais en
fait faut que des têtes attendait royal
avions alors là les gens on va pas
refaire un truc de dingue je crois et tu
fais quoi là pas mais voilà tu paies
arette 2 b tu vas pas chier tu as well
as fait peur on se fait attaquer vous
allez où j'ai des petits cadeaux pour
vous revenez larves et la voilà vous
êtes curieux bat wil vous êtes curieux
c'est l'attraction du jour un doute
esquive à aller matin même je suis pas
foutu de vider à oui et quand même
dis moi quelle bouteille d'alcool dedans
c'est une petite surprise que je
concocte pour vous hélas non besbas du
12è je voulais faire je suis désolé
voilà bon j'espère que ya une autre
bouteille qui traîne quelque part puce
plus alcool + pièce égal bon ben on les
attire
regardez troc attention attention merde
mais non mais le truc non attendez aux
maisons mais j'ai arrêté ma bombe
oui oui c'est ce qu'on appelle bayer oui
mais tais toi toi baptême ont fait chier
dans toutes les vidéos du haka mais je
vais vous montrer comment ça se passe
dans la vie quand tu veux m'attaquer
tumeur 1 et la petite dernière
elle brûle aussi c'est comme ça que ça
se passe dans la vie alors maintenant
vous avez tout gentiment de donner vos
têtes
et puis tu que ça alors elle ou la tête
et où la tête est là hello hello la tête
c'est un caillou ça pour les mouettes
servent à quelque chose ce n'est pas moi
cherchez la tête
oh [ __ ] 11-0 s'est réveillé nous
agresser direct quoi elle part au
courant bas va chercher le petit déj
aller en tout cas je te remercie ça me
ferait peut-être de plus pour un
collectif un dernier round 1 est la
fuite est à nous tu as qu il est prêt il
est prêt on peut on peut le pousser dans
l'eau bien sûr qu'on peut le pousser
dans l'eau on va s'enfuir mais avant je
tiens à laisser une trace de ma présence
sur cette île la bombe s'est rapproché
vous boum boum boum et au mexique
c'est pas une vraie bombe ce à quoi
c'est un pétard chinois ça s'appelle ok
on va contrôler de mort et on est bon la
tête la tête c'est ça c'est ça
après deux vidéos 100% fail et jean
audin réussi à faire tout ce que vous
voulez on a dégommé de l'indigène on a
fait un non mais attends il manque une
tête non
non mais une tête qui traînent dans le
coin oui regardez que moi ta tête
patatras voilà ces hausses à brühl
carrément abattant mais c'est bien trop
stylé craignait ma puissance indigènes
fou c'est l'heure de s'en aller et de
partir à la maison vient la petit radeau
viala allez on y va petit radeau il faut
qu on contourne les requins c'est bravo
passe en plein dedans
j'ai un peu peur je pense qu'il ya moyen
de les tuer avec le harpon attendait au
nom allait rater mon gars ok 2 contres
et 1 pas de problème esquive ya pas
besoin de monter sur son dos sinon que
s'amuser tin tin tin tin tin tin tin tin
à sa boîte shot
ah oui pas d'accord et bloque pas le
requin mais j'avais sauvegarder est vrai
les gens c'est afin de 7,3 et vidéo sur
ce fort est je pense que je fais une
vidéo sur le jeu tous les sept jours
c'est à dire à chaque fois que tu auras
une mise à jour de l'alfa parce que là
serait comme un peu marrant le truc du
bateau l'espèce de grottes on a vu des
des araignées femmes ci a moins fait son
choix en switch bas on se retrouvera
tous deux nouvelles vidéos de chatons
monde mx